and Shan pen joins me now Sean great to
see you it's been quite a while 10 years
I think since I last interviewed you
yeah that we're in a world of
self-identity are you here identifying
as an actor a humanitarian an activist
or something else good qu I suppose I'm
here identifying as somebody who'd like
to get eyes and ears on this film
superpower and and uh and a continued
conversation on our obligations to
Ukraine the the film I've watched it
twice I think it's a great film than and
it couldn't be more timely because due
to events in the Middle East with the
Israel Hamas War a lot of global
attention has moved away from Ukraine
and president zalinski who I know you
know well and I went to ke and
interviewed him myself is very concerned
that while the world looks away Vladimir
Putin will accelerate his attempt to
effectively take as much of Ukraine as
he can get how perilous do you think
this moment is for
Ukraine I think the way I equate it is
how perilous is it for mankind in our
general
um Mission Focus be that with our
families or with the World At
Large there are not too many
distractions available to get us off
course if we don't let there be the
concerns in the Middle East are of
course very reing
great but with with the principles
intact that it those in the world who
believe in in Freedom whether whether
you call it democracy or something
else we're not given more to do than
we're able to do and I think it's just a
the the micro stuff and the breaking
down of each other in all of this is
really the distraction that we should
worry about obviously that's manipulated
by enemies it was never I never felt
that for example President Putin's trip
to Teran was strictly about drones and I
do believe that there was an influence
on what happened October 7th uh in Gaza
in in
Israel uh that that that that too was
influenced by this so these things have
connections and and so to defeat those
things and for freedom to Triumph is to
be able to maintain focus on both and
the other issues of the day there's a
fascinating moment in the movie I'm
going to come to the movie in a lot more
depth a little later but there's a
fascinating moment about Freedom where Z
reveals he came to America I think in
the late 80s as an impressionable young
man to see what freedom and democracy
actually looked like and it was that
that inspired him to want freedom of
this kind for his own country yes yes
yeah that really that really hit home
with me because it was almost the
inversion of that that I was
experiencing having you know talked
myself into believing that I had been
living in a free country uh but what
does free mean and free really has to
include a sense of unity community and
yes diverse opinions but deal dealt with
in civil and productive ways for
tomorrow and for the the more long term
and when I got to Ukraine and I felt
that so embedded in its current culture
I realized what I'd been missing and I
said said that in the film uh it it
really was at once incredibly tragic of
course the reasons that that what's forc
them into this kind of high moment of
incredible Unity is is devastating and
yet it's another opportunity for
humankind to to look at itself and say
what is it we really need so that we
have a quality of life that we can share
with each other do you see parallels
between what's happening in Israel and
Gaza and the Ukraine Russia
War well of course there are certain
parallels um you know
the the want and disregard for and in
fact proactive attack back on civilians
on children on
infrastructure and and the biggest
parallel I suppose the most the one I
think we could spend our time most
productively focusing
on
is the way in which and this extends to
so much else the way in which uh Nuance
is not allowed into the
conversation now what's not a parallel
in the case of you know what's not
nuanced at all in the Ukraine Russia
conflict or rather Russia's criminal
invasion of
Ukraine is that's a very um
unambiguous set of circumstances it's a
very clear
um black hat involved here a black hat
against all our human principles with
Russia's horrible and and and misguided
Invasion and all the murder and all all
of the taking of children and
re-educating of children to hate their
parents and their country and things we
just shouldn't stand for as any s single
section of
it my sense is that and I'm not an
expert on the Middle East but my sense
is certainly that there with the horror
of what Hamas has done that to get to a
productive result
for Jews for Israelis for Arabs in
Israel for Arabs in Gaza and the West
Bank and and around the Middle
East we might not like it but it's going
to take a very nuanced conversation and
and and and the sooner we get to it the
better and the more push there is or
resistance to that conversation it will
histor the Legacy will be that those who
pushed against the nuanced conversation
would have been the ones to have
extended the problem you recently told
variety magazine before what's just
blown up in the in the Middle East if
you'd been US president after 911 you'd
have done things different you said if I
have to go to prison I'll go but I'm
going to kill them I'm killing everyone
that did this but only them and we know
where the fers they are where the F they
are in the context of that gut response
that you had to 9911 do you understand
why Israel has reacted the way it's done
even if you don't endorse it but you
understand their desire their fervent
need as a country to go after Hamas and
eliminate the people that perpetrated
the the terror attack were Hamas living
in remote mountains of taborah I I would
have absolutely understood it but when
you have a place like you know
topographically similar let's say it's
Malibu California in size and scope and
Al though a hundred times more populated
you know when we think of Gaza we do
have to understand Tak without taking a
side being a Defender apologist for
anything those children are here hearing
every gunshot throughout the country
yeah are feeling every ordinance that
drops this is
24/7 it's this is a tiny Place packed
with people that's very diff I I I would
say absolutely I would like to see Hamas
evaporated in mountains like Tabor as
perhaps could have Al Qaeda at that time
see that's that's my moral quandry with
what's happening right now with Israel
and Hamas because I completely believe
that they have a fundamental right and
duty to their citizens to stop Hamas
doing what they did again and Hamas have
said publicly we're going to try and do
it again and again and again but the
particularly unique makeup of Gaza with
half the population being children means
that if you do a a constant bombardment
for many weeks is the way the Israelis
have done you're going to kill thousands
and thousands of completely innocent
children and I find that morally
repugnant that that's happening and yet
I defend their moral right to go after
Hamas it's it's a really it's a
difficult situation isn't it it's very
difficult of course one has to be very
aware you know that could have been my
my daughter or son at that music
festival for example I mean it I
understand the immediate reaction to
that even the longterm reaction to it
but again we we do have to also say well
if somebody else's children next time
and when I brought up when I said that I
felt that you know that I had a dream
that President Bush might just say I'm
sending the White House Council home
this has to be done we'll suffer the
consequences later in toror with Al
Qaeda I also said that I that having
done that he might have licensed himself
to then go back in time and say in what
ways again we know this is these are the
kind of things that people love to chew
apart in what ways did
we
was were we complicit in the poverty in
the hopelessness in the oppression of a
people somewhere else and the lack of
inclusivity of those people that
contributed to to to that hatred that
that came our way so in this case
too there's there are the big
differences one is the civilian
population of Gaza and the other
is the that we are told not to speak
about the accountability of Israel and
the United States in their support of
Israel uh in many ways unconditional
support and you know I'm
48% ashkanazi Jew right um I
have nothing but love for my ancestry
and
ancestors that doesn't have anything to
do with the fact that I think that while
Israel's people
were criminally horrifyingly
attacked that Israel also has a prime
minister who is a
terror by any measure of basic political
thinking that's bad timing you think
he's an actual terrorist n well I didn't
say terrorist um I wouldn't necessarily
jump to say that because I think they I
don't know that he's cry trying to
create Terror so much as he's trying to
create inflated sense of his own worth
in his
time your father the acttion director
Leo pen uh as you said an American Jew
of Eastern European descent also a
highly decorated War veteran he served
as a tail Gunner and bombarder in the
B24 Liberator with the US Air Force in
World War II actually stationed here in
England that's right and of course was
fighting the Nazis which were an
existential threat to civilization at
the time you know many Israelis say what
they're going through now is the worst
existential threat to what happened to
them in the Holocaust um your dad was an
amazing guy life expectancy for the role
that he played in that war was seven
missions he did 37 he did is that where
you get this Warrior Spirit from uh I I
would only aspire to um I've never been
tested like that uh yeah but he is uh
the hero in my uh my exper
what would he what would he do you think
have made of what's Happening Now with
Israel and what advice would he give
them do you think to try and get to a
better
place my dad used to have an expression
when I would come home very opinionated
on one issue or another and very angry
at anyone who believed differently he
would say you know everyone has their
own Truth Kid and I think his advice
would be for people to recognize what is
true of each other's position
and then it's also important to
recognize what is a lie that one that
that group thinkers tell themselves to
be comfortable and to have a group and
an identity and I think this extends
again to the the broader cultural
picture of a lot of What's um
distracting from us getting down to the
things that will help our world be
better well it's it's become so toxic
and tribal the debate driven I think by
social media people belong to tribes on
social media facts don't matter it's
just all about being completely One Way
completely another and then shrieking at
each other not there's never any
consensus people never admit they're
wrong they never move with facts it's
just about being tribal I've really
noticed that in the last 15 years since
Twitter Facebook you know Tik Tok
Instagram and so on yeah and we're if we
don't attack it culturally we all know
that the technology is now increasingly
there exponentially growing every day uh
for idiots to operate as
successfully as Brilliant Minds uh to
create a sort of impenetrably real
seeming reflections of a world that are
falsehood AI for example I saw a
demonstration done someone who uh a
friend of mine involved in Ai and he he
doesn't speak any Japanese
but he was able to look straight in the
camera and speak whatever he his it was
and then the AI takes not only his voice
as it would speak proper Japanese but
also Alters the movement of the mouth to
house that and it's seamless so we've
got a lot of surprises coming it's uh
someone did that to me for a TED talk
with me promoting use of guns when I was
campaigning against the NRA it was
frightening it was so realistic I almost
believed it was me yeah and that was
several years ago so God knows what
they're capable of now yeah and if and
if anyone thinks that the United States
is not in the crosshairs of Russia well
just keep watching some of what happens
in that way yeah um you've been very
scathing of America's lack of what you
think is proper support particularly
with Ukraine with regard to their
ability to control the air you would
like to have seen America Supply X F-16
Fighters and so on why do you feel so
strongly about that first I think and
most of the military strategists that
I've had an opportunity to talk to and
that's a cross-section of some of what
are incredibly described as the best
Minds in that um space I feel that this
war would have been over by now had that
happened Not only would it have been
over but you know from my the
personalized point of view friends of
mine would not be dead who are dead now
who were Fighters yes in Ukraine and and
uh I think that you know that there is a
point where caution becomes cowardice it
it it doesn't have to be personal
cowardice it could be the way that we re
identify our
country's um tenor and I I it's cons
very disappointing heartbreaking to me
that we've been given this opportunity
and so far let it down more than we have
supported it there's a lot of talk of
how we've supported it even the
president and and the government of
Ukraine you know are constantly grateful
uh for the support of the United States
but I think we all know that it has been
um substandard wouldn't be a fair word
when so many are dying and just as
importantly substandard wouldn't be a
good enough word when so much of the
American aspiration is systematically
dying with it we need to step up every
day is another
opportunity um the ukrainians are
certainly uh ready to fight the fight
they've never asked for our troops to be
on the ground or in the air and there's
been a lot of sort of smoke and mirror
talk about how long it would take
whether there were the maintenance Crews
available there there's actually been
workarounds available on that from the
very beginning and and within the first
months of the war there could have been
f-16s without American the reason of
course I think was behind them being
hesitant was they didn't want to trigger
a wider conflict with the nuclear power
and you said this about that I use the
word cowardice because I don't know any
other word to describe what happens when
we argue caution as restraint restraint
looks like John F Kennedy holding back
military action during the Cuba Missile
Crisis that's a powerful piece of
leadership caution looks like I'm scared
the bad guys are going to do something
if I do what's right so let's do nothing
or let's do just enough that won't get
me more scared I thought that was so
spoton because all Putin's had to do in
this war is rattle his nuclear
capability cage and everyone's like oh
my God we can't we can't risk World War
I right well in fact logically why would
he do that is my point about that
America has almost as many nuclear
weapons as he does if he did press that
button everyone dies well reasonably
it's unlikely that he' do it that we
have to take it seriously that
possibility but the tradeoff is seems
simple not it is doesn't mean we're
ready to let him take over because this
without the proper resistance without
the proper support of Ukraine this
doesn't stop it'll be the baltics first
it'll go it'll go on Poland it'll go on
and on and on if he sees that all these
guy do is bark with that weapon yeah
that's what I think also there's a
betrayal of the ukrainians with nuclear
weapons we made them give theirs up if
they had had those nuclear weapons I
don't think Putin would have
countenanced invading but he knew he
could invade a non-nuclear power with
impunity but if they'd been able to keep
their weapons they wouldn't have been a
non-nuclear power and and Americans
should know particularly you know we did
sign the Budapest memorandum and that
did assure Ukraine that if they gave up
those weapons Russia the United States
and the other and the others involved
would never even
threaten uh intervention or violence
against the country I've got a clip this
is from a 2001 Moscow Film Festival you
and Jack Nicholson actually meeting
Vladimir Putin have you been to
Russia
in 2001 Jack Nicholson and I had a film
at the Moscow Film
Festival that night has become a deviant
memory a deviant memory what is your
memory of that
meeting I remember this was
approximately two weeks after the famous
meeting between President Bush and and
Putin um where President Bush said
something like you know I looked him in
the eye and I knew it could trust them I
I didn't come away with a great uh I
don't mean a good or bad impression a
deep impression at the time he was a you
know a bit of a a a poker-faced fellow
uh talked about his kids there was there
were no politics discussed per se but
when I talk about it as a deviant memory
you know I look at
that and now you know World head of
state aside World politics aside I'm
looking at somebody who's
you know cutting off baby's heads I
don't like having been next to
that he um has banned you from Russia
banned me I've also had that badge of
honor as I see it there goes that
summering in St Petersburg trip we were
planning well I mean exactly I got
banned literally a few days after I came
back from ke just for interviewing
president zalinski um and we were deemed
enemies of the state in Russia um
Putin I mean to me demonstrably he's a
war criminal should he be held to proper
account for the war crimes he's been
committing well of course he should but
I think right now that you know how that
all winds down um when he is reduced as
I as as I believe will happen to a
negotiation for
himself I'm less concerned about that
than seeing uh Russia
relent um recognize the territory the
complete territory of Ukraine recognize
its obligation uh to towards
reconstruction I think there in the
United States I think there are $30
billion dollar of Frozen Frozen Russian
assets uh were that released to Ukraine
um I think others allies would follow
and I think the the total bag is about
$300 billion so there is there's already
money in hand uh to support Ukraine that
way and what happens with him
is at this moment still for me u a
decision for the ukrainians primarily
you I don't know if you've got it on you
now but for a long time you carried a
card in your wallet uh by the great
armenian-american author William serin
and there was a quote from this I think
part of a lengthier quote but there's a
bit that says despise evil and
ungodliness but not men of ungodliness
or evil evil these understand have no
shame in being kindly and gentle but if
the time comes in the time of your life
to kill kill and have no regret it's a
powerful quote it is yeah I don't think
I knew what it meant really until like I
said as you said I carried that around
forever it made some visceral impact on
me and I could tell I could recognize
the kind of the rhythm of the thoughts
in a way that was provocative more
provocative to say than anything i' I'd
read in a short form like that and so I
I I kept it with me thinking I knew what
it meant but sort of like the way an
onion gets peeled it wasn't until I got
to Ukraine where I really felt like okay
now I understand this thing does any
part of you understand as he wrote there
about Putin clearly a man of evil many
would say I certainly would um but if
you're playing Devil's Advocate trying
to get into his brain do you understand
why this guy thought the breakup of the
Soviet Union was the worst thing ever
happened to his country felt like the
NATO encroachment as he saw it closer
and closer to the Russian border was a
threat to the Russian people I mean does
any part of that make any sense to you
or do you think it's just an excuse for
his land grab I think we all know people
even from our own communities sometimes
within our own families who for whatever
reasons their principal nature in their
in their
life has had either is absent some
imagination or has had that imagination
somehow
paralyzed it's what I call kind of the
bulb no bulb people you see the light of
humanity in some
people I I I so whatever the sort of
speculation is and I've read some of the
histories of Putin and seen some of the
documentaries and I've certainly Listen
to Better brains than mine uh talk about
that and sort of analyze
him I think essentially what this is is
an
unimaginative person someone who whose
bulb either never got F put on and
therefore was not distracted by the
colors of life that the rest of us uh
Embrace and so there's a certain kind of
savantism that is vulnerable to
becoming oh simplistic in the kind of
great ideas or great senses of Pride it
can be housed by a country or by its
leader so we're really dealing with
something uninteresting and
childish and we see that that can be a
very dangerous thing Donald Trump says
he would resolve this war in 24
hours I think in the United States
Donald Trump is guilty most of being a
um
adolescent uh um
influencer of cheap and cheap
thought and cheap thought is very
expensive it's it again I go back to
what America should be searching for and
a democrat or a republican it's an
aspirational figure not someone you hang
your your lowest denominator on you
called him Trump an enemy of mankind and
compassion well I think that again maybe
it's overestimating him to say that but
certainly the effect of him or what he
symbolizes of the disease we've allowed
to be normalized up into and including
him so it's time and this is why I think
it's so important for all of us to be
talking to each other again you know no
matter whether we're on different sides
of things or not because we don't have
to give it up to leadership on the level
that we have we can really start to
reshape this and and take take lead from
very small ways and forward and trying
you know it's it's it's hard I you know
I've been on the inflammatory circuit
quite a bit myself uh but I really you
know I'm working hard and working hard
with some Republican friends to try to
um you know in our little way even
reframe that debate and I hope Sean
Hannity show on Fox News which I thought
was a really interesting moment when you
did that that's a big deal for you to do
that you're going into what I guess
would have been historically a kind of
media enemies Lair yeah but you were
prepared to do that to have that debate
and it was a very interesting interview
as you you know there's a there's a I'm
sure it's been thrown at you uh a lot of
I I probably used more by the left than
the right um the left with whom I'm more
generally identified and I and I would
identify
myself but I I think this term bomb
thrower you know I've heard him referred
to by the left is a bomb thrower we're
in a world now where we really got to
pay attention to what a real bomb
thrower looks like and that's a bomb and
that's bodies on the pavement some of
them are children and that's the
destruction of infrastructure and that's
cold through the winter that's you know
that's while there's incredible
influence by media figures by political
figures um if somebody has had no
experience with real bomb throwers
perhaps they should hold that that
phrase and come up with something uh
more particular to what their concern is
because it it just makes it again an
extra it's a you know exaggerated and or
or or just a perversion of what's really
going
on I don't know about you but most
people I talk to once you get it off the
standard conversation of policy or
personality around the world they want
the same thing they want a better world
for themselves and their family tomorrow
they want education for their kids it's
it's the most common and they could be
quite reasonable however unreasonable
they may have sounded and you get when
you get past that you can have a what
used to be perfectly normal conversation
in a free Democratic Society right but
now we're in a world where cancel
culture is a very real thing right and
you know you know better than anyone the
dangers of this what happened to your
father who was ostracized by Hollywood
when he wouldn't throw his friends under
the bus when there was that huge you
know what was it the the big
investigation into whether whether they
were Communists or whatever it may be he
refused to take part in that and he
never really got his career back as a
result that was cancel culture and of
course he played Harvey Milk again a
perfect illustration of what a world can
do when it wants to cancel people now
it's so much more prevalent now yeah
it's like people get canceled for having
an opinion just saying what they
honestly believe about stuff yeah how
have we got
there I I say I would you know I'm a
little bit borrowing from stepen fry
here he he he gives this great closing
argument at the end of a monk debate on
political correctness and I
think maybe and it will seem ironic that
that I respond this way maybe we've
taken ourselves too
seriously and have you
included uh perhaps at the Forefront
many
times
well I think it's because you do
genuinely care passionately I've always
felt that about you whether it's been
over Haiti whether it's when you went to
Iraq you went to Iran you went to Syria
to see Assad know even when you went to
trying and get to El Chapo you know I've
always felt that what's driving you is
that you believe dialogue should be held
and should be constructive yeah I think
taking our world seriously we can do a
lot more effectively if we take
ourselves more lightly in it um
especially when we sort
of adhere to
self-righteousness uh and yes you know
again I I I I understand how I've been a
part of that many times try you know
each day you try to put your foot
forward um and I and I right now my
focus I suppose is is what's going to
happen in my country and both for itself
and and for its impact on the world you
said that you fly a big American and
Ukrainian flag at your home in Malibu he
said I'm a big proponent of the idea we
start waving flags again even if we're
on the left and we don't worry that our
neighbors are going to think we suddenly
became a Maga Hawk which is what some of
my friends accuse me of just for having
an American flag flying yeah but again
that apparently is now offensive the
left will the left a lot of friends of
mine well you know we got to take the
flag back
or we gotta share it again yes yes I
mean it's interesting isn't it that
countries find true Unity often in the
worst possible circumstance I felt that
when I went to New York after 9/11 it
felt like the whole country was United
in that moment in a way I hadn't seen
America probably in my lifetime
similarly I think you know you had the
same experience with Haiti and how the
Haitians came together I certainly felt
it I think you did in Ukraine that the
Ukrainian people were just almost
completely as one in in their desire to
save their country Reserve their freedom
back their president that wasn't the
case before the war started no but all
the more I mean as important as our
support of them to to to dominate this
to to return their freedom and
sovereignty to themselves and to rebuild
their country is is the long-term plan
this is the opportunity for mankind for
all freeth thinking why can't we unify
sir that we remember that once that's
resolved we have to have
the spirit and resources in place for it
to be the example of it continuing
Beyond them unified under war that was
the question I going to ask leading
example why do we find it so hard to
continue the unity when we get back to a
more peaceful time I think I think
unities are cannibalized first by those
who are promoting
Unity I think we' you know things blow
up from the inside of an idea and you
know I think even
I think even with the in the case of
Russia uh after
1994 you know I remember the relief the
Cold War is Over people are dancing I
never I don't think we ever looked back
and noticed that the Russians were not
feeling the relief that the world was
feeling and that gangsterism had
replaced communism and the bread lines
were just as long and they were it
things didn't get better for them and
you let that happen over time and
somebody like Putin is able to come back
take power and do what he's doing we
need strong leadership never more so
than from America Joe Biden is seen as
somebody who is just too old frankly for
the challenges of the world right now do
you do you agree with
that what i' say is this is that whether
he's too old or not we do recognize that
the optic is is is largely going that
way uh you know that the binary Choice
that's talked about is Donald Trump
or um until somebody steps
forward to say they would enter this
race I don't care what party but
somebody who would be a stronger uh
president than Joe Biden then there's
not much use in my talking about
it except to say that you know we don't
know what capable of certainly our
general impression seems to be that you
know it's it's it's getting it it's look
I think about myself at 63 it's harder
to do the leg work right than it used to
be so and he's 81 I think yeah I mean
and you know Trump's knows spring
chicken and what he's shooting himself
to have energy I don't know and what how
what effect that has on his mind but he
started off at at a deficit it was was
only going to hurt the country in the
world does it worry you the thought that
Trump may win again
because nothing they're throwing at him
seems to make any difference in fact it
all seems to increase his popularity all
these indictments and so on I know
there's a lot of speculation that he may
and a lot of speculation that he may not
I think that my concern would if I could
I'd like an x-ray of who we are in
America today is that really possible
because before Trump that would be the
problem if we if we're still ready to
let everything we stand for and
everything my father's generation and
those before stood for and I don't mean
that they accomplished all their tasks
for everybody we know that never
happened and then we hope it still can
but if we go soft and yellow and decide
we're going to let it go and let this
guy as judge suda once said take the
ball and roll with it
um then you know I'm going to have to
find my pride in a glass of
vodka might take more than one glass of
VOD um let's talk about
superpower it's fascinating to me that
this began this movie as a much lighter
film that you wanted to make about this
extraordinary story of a guy who was an
actor a comedic actor predominantly um
you know he'd been seen playing the
piano with his penis on a special on TV
for the delectation of Ukrainian people
and they all laughed um then he takes
part in this in this series called
servant of the people where as a
comedian actor he ends up becoming
president of Ukraine right and we got a
clip
for such a powerful clip that because
it's so preent because this guy then
becomes the real president of Ukraine
and very quickly has a very bad guy and
other bad guys coming to take his
country yeah uh it's and that in that
moment your whole film that you've been
making which is a light fun look at a
guy who's a comedy actor and you're an
actor and you think this is fun and then
it gets incredibly serious and
fascinatingly right to the point of War
you've detected from your film making
there he's not that popular right people
think he's he's in bed with corrupt
oligarchs his big popularity when he got
elected is all dissipated most people
are fact everyone I think you speak to
either says I wouldn't vote for him or I
wouldn't vote for him again even the
ones so this is not a popular guy right
and yet in that moment of the ultimate
Challenge he he becomes a completely
different character for you as a
filmmaker but you was an actor what did
you make of all this well personally it
it's one more time where I could say you
know I try to be light and then pull me
back in you know we here we really did
Alo go f suck me back in yeah um you
know it's interesting and I take it back
a little bit to when we're talking about
President Biden
there's there's a you this is somebody
who
has been an extraordinary person of
service for so long understands the game
very deeply the process the bureaucratic
process and I think has a lot to offer I
I wish that we had a reverence for the
sort of Elder Statesman position that
could serve in this way and not have to
go state to state to state to shake
hands and smile with babies to be
elected president and and so I you know
I as one American citizen I would like
to to to see the possibility of you know
a kind of heightened position for
somebody like if if President Biden
decides not to run at some point I know
there's no suggestion of that but I
think that that could be there could be
a great value in something like that um
this situation was it was so um you know
we met president zinski the first time I
had I had said because of what I thought
could be a value added documentary that
I could make versus some accomplished
documentarian or
journalist uh that that that it's always
been a kind of a trust and
trustworthiness Bond and maybe it would
be a different kind of conversation I
don't and therefore I didn't want to
have a camera available the first time
we we met face to face and it was just a
crazy Coincidence of timing that we met
the first time on the 23rd without a
camera literally the day before the war
starts right and agreed that on the 24th
we do our first session with the camera
and
unbelievably he sees you he he fulfilled
the commitment despite the Rockets
coming in we've got a clip of
[Music]
this
here home where where does it end what
does he want what does he what is the he
wants to he wants he wants us to be dead
he he he hate UK he he hate us I we
don't know
why I mean it's incredible the war
starts and he takes time to see you and
no offense but Shan pen you're an actor
were you surprised he kept that meeting
and why do you think he did I was
surprised of course I'm was surprised um
you know we were all processing a u the
tragedy of of this unimaginable decision
of
Putin's
um today I I understand it better uh I
think he's
very Savvy uh I think that any
opportunity to have a record of
I think he believed in what he was going
to do and what his people were going to
do so much so that in a country at
War we were never uh watched over when
we were shooting we never had a minder
there was never a word of influencing
anything
really and when you talk to him as you
did you know I
sense more so than many um people in
leadership around the world that I've
met that I many of whom I like and
admire a lot there generally is some
level of selling the
agenda he's so consistently genuine and
extemporaneous and I think when you know
I guess it goes to when you have nothing
to hide and when you have a clear vision
of something you can let somebody see
right into it and not be so guarded and
so
here I think he probably anticipated the
potential value of anyone who might get
a uh a a a
platform for Ukraine especially in
America as this yeah he knew how
important America would be and he
thought using a Hollywood Superstar osc
multiple Oscar winner would shine a
light right when he needed it to get
help from America that's that's a guy
who understands the media understands
politics possibly from playing a
president in a comedy I mean it's
surreal the way you guys came together
like this yeah and another way to look
at it is you you know when I'm remember
I've been very focused and had a lot of
responsibility I'm not comparing it to
the responsibility he has but but I've
had responsibilities in certain
situations to a lot of people and
sometimes to their physical well-being
and uh you know you do find that moment
where your bandwidth needs to step
outside and have a cigarette it may be
that you know he used this opportunity
obious say he stepped outside and
essentially had a cigarette yeah uh you
know it doesn't mean that it's like he
took time out of fighting a war he was
also Shan at the time on that day the
number one Target in the country yeah
for Putin you were warned by your team
look we need to get out of here because
they're probably going to do a strike
right here highly likely I mean that was
more likely than not and yet you stayed
to to see him did you not think that was
a particularly dangerous moment in your
life I've had times where I've had
anxiety about certain situations I've
been in in Conflict zones and so on but
never but statistically never like a you
know long-term journalist who are there
for or the people who live there or the
soldiers that fight the fight so
statistically I was safe um and then you
know it just was so overwhelmingly
heartbreaking because I knew this was
going to affect my kids it's the whole
world in a way that I'd not seen before
or known before and I think the worst of
that may yet to be yet to come if we
don't we the Allies NATO get behind this
country in a real real aggressive way
but I I just didn't feel it I didn't
feel I think uh Sadat one time said you
know I'm going to die but not one second
before God says so didn't feel like this
was going to change that it was a moment
when you go to the front line this is
about 4 months later and a woman says
this to
you I think that because of our
proximity now to active combat that's
where our sights should be
set it's uh about 10 km from zero
position that's the
priority can I be very blunt your Sean
pan nobody's going to be responsible for
you dying on the front
line
I mean that's the moment when you hear
that because that's completely true the
front line doesn't care who you are how
many Oscars You've Won you end up 150
meters away from Russians across a river
um not withstanding you've been in a few
hairy situations in your life that that
must have been a seriously unnerving
moment wasn't
it I think you make a decision when you
get on an airplane you know
where even if big turbulence comes if
you're not a pilot you you can you can
get as anxious as you want it doesn't
really matter what you're going to do
about it if something's going to happen
uh of course I took a deep breath at
some point before we went in but I I
also felt that you know and what's here
um uh I think quite graciously that that
voice who was uh working as a translator
with us she she you know offered an
abundant abundant of caution um but
again it's almost an embarrassing thing
to I understand the question and you
know there's some versions of of this I
could say differently but you know when
when I think
of people who are staying there in that
fight uh you know versus parachuting in
for a second and getting a little bit of
a story and and going out I I I don't
really know how to talk about that but I
I I this was this was mostly uh felt
obligatory to the story we were telling
to go there and you know to at least
touch base with that and um there's a
moment when you go to an apartment block
this is in your first visit after the
war started in June and you see the
devastation for yourself of a air stripe
that had happened just a few hours
before and what was particularly telling
for me uh as I watched you do this was I
suddenly realized that this was the same
apartment block I'd gone to a month
after you when I did a show or two shows
from from ke and walked in I'm pretty
sure the same apartment block um and I
don't know how you felt when I but I I
felt just I'd never been in that kind of
I'm not a war correspondent I don't
normally go to places like this and just
to see the utter Devastation of just in
that case one person's life yeah now
they everything destroyed all their
little possessions gone tiny fragments
of dolls and so on just a life destroyed
you know and some people die and some
people live but they have everything
that they own taken from them it was a
pretty you know for me it was a
real I guess a moment of realization of
the reality of of what Warfare actually
involves it's not just Frontline soldier
soldier it is the constant barrage of
civilian life and orary people families
separated for two years while the men
stay to to fight the fight or support
the fight in in country and the mothers
and the children who are spread out all
over the world some you know with no
promise of anywhere or any to go or any
support and in some cases getting you
know other worldly support Poland in
particular was you both the civilians
and the leadership were extraordinary uh
toward them uh but still that's walking
out into a Brave New World and and you
know just worrying every day about your
brother or your father son who's in the
fight you dedicate the film to Ukrainian
fighter pilot called Andre pil chov
known as juice he was the leader of the
Fable ghost of Kiev unit which didn't
actually exist in the way people thought
but he was an unbelievably Good Pilot
and he very sadly died three months ago
yeah in a training exercise you see in
the movie you take him to see top gun
Maverick he's a real life Top Gun you
saw it in Washington when you were
lobbying for F-16 Jets and he's now one
of the 100,000 ukrainians who died in
this war um including I think 13,000
civilians tell me about him for a moment
I mean the impact he had on your
life well I'd like to say we became
friends we we kept in touch after we
spent time in Washington I I might um
you know we'd be on an encrypted line
that he was okay with and I might you
know say Hey you know what's happening
and he said just about to go wheels up
and he'd be because they were they were
constantly in the
fight um he was a very poetic creature
you know not what you would expect of a
Top Gun essentially Top Gun fire pilot
uh he was a great leader uh and I know
many in his Squadron um and he really
was as much as any individual that they
were speaking of when they came up with
the you know the the the oneoff of the
ghost of kib um his mother Lilia is a
force
uh and I think will ultimately be
considered you know the the mother of
the Ukrainian Air Force she's uh their
supporting and supported by uh all the
guys in his Squadron as they now begin
the you know the program we have 16s
which is take some time but is is now
finally ongoing not supported well
enough but beginning at least uh
he's a guy who
believed he owed his country service
he's not he was a yeah sort of
personality-wise the furthest thing you
you'd think from a military man and u a
beautiful spirit uh and great humor heat
you know most people know that movie Top
Gun Maverick and when we were watching
it in DC I was sitting next to him and
he he leaned over at one point after Tom
Cruz had ejected uh and and uh found his
way in his Dusty flight suit to the to
the to the diner and he lean over and he
said that's why I always take my
wallet how did you how did you find out
that he
died so um somebody I no I don't know I
mean if he would mind my saying his name
you can assume who it is from let's say
the civilian now someone who had worked
in government who would have known
anything the New York Times Knew by the
time the New York Times anything where
you collect open source material and a
per very credible person
um called me middle of the night and
said no because I'd introduced the two
of them in DC and knew that I would want
to know and said this happened and then
I double checked it with the ministry of
Defense in Ukraine and they came back
and said
yep s
m
yeah what is it but sort of like what
talking about with the apartment
right it's it's personalized yeah and
it's personalized tens of thousands of
times you you were angry when the
academy uh just after the war blew up
decided not to let zalinsky speak of the
Oscars and then of course that Oscars
became known for the Will Smith Chris
Rock to punch up on stage which you
don't think would have happened if
zinski had been allowed to speak because
the idea of someone then committing an
act of violence publicly at the same
event would have been Unthinkable right
yeah I I
mean the there was if what what are
films you know it's not just the cellula
you print them on it's bigger medicine
than that you know it can be uh
and so their ideas their
stories what more Cinema idea or story
is is there or more identified with film
a film star also a filmmaker
zalinski what's more appropriate at that
moment in time to address the Academy
Awards he had no intention of being um
part partisan politics in the United
States it was really to talk about the
value of Cinema and to thank all of
those around the world that were
supporting and and the academy that's
what he he would have shared and that
they traded that for I guess the karma
of what happened with Will Smith it it
it you know you look at Will Smith whose
performance
was great as King Richard just
and why amazing this Petty kind of thing
happens I was in I was back uh and a
part of the trip that was more related
to my organization core back in Ukraine
in at this point in leiv when that
happened and I you know literally I felt
were you watching I feel no I couldn't
wasn't watching it but I heard about it
in the morning after and saw the clip
and and I literally felt something like
safer in Ukraine than Hollywood watching
it you know mentally how it just seemed
so small and when you in your earlier
Incarnation pun somebody you got a
60-day jail sentence served half of it
in prison yeah Will Smith goes back up
to receive the best actor award after
whacking somebody at the Oscars live and
gets an ovation from the audience yeah
that Ovation should be I that that
should be played on this show a lot of
times to because the shame on them you
know it it's so yeah I I just felt that
that was a a very low moment in uh in in
whatever the leadership of the academy
denying this thing having you know or
the producer of that particular show
being so of such um lack of substance
uh it was discouraging yeah what did you
what do you think was going through Will
Smith's hate it was so shocking I don't
know we've all heard different stories
and speculations I I don't I I don't
know I just think it was
a uh it could have been averted had the
first decision been a brave and Noble
one before it got to him you um were so
angry about this you wanted to melt down
your two Oscars for bullets Ukrainian
soldiers to use against the Russians and
in the end you didn't do it but you gave
one of your Oscars to president zalinski
but on loan and you said when this War's
over bring it back to Malibu we've got a
clip of what you'd like to do when you
see him after this war
ends
I hope I really hope that when he's an
old man and I'm an even older one that I
might be sitting with him in a peaceful
and prosperous free
ke laughing like a couple of kids at
what William seryan called the infinite
delight and
mystery of
life it's a lovely thought um but you
must have had quite quite a few moments
not least when you left Kei that first
time on the day war had broken out and
you were able to leave and he was left
there that you might never see him again
of course yeah it was a it was it
creeped up on me by surprise because you
know when you're in a when you meet
somebody who's in circumstances that
reasonably could end in any way any way
you can
imagine and where there were
such clear Intentions by you know our
it's understood that there were chatch
and kill squads in the streets of K who
were targeting he and his family at that
time so they it was coming at it from
all angles the potential targeting of
government
buildings snipers everything and that he
was this target you you know you you you
you make a decision faster emotionally
and and I I recognized my affection for
him so I felt I can't speak for him and
this he had a lot of things to respond
to but I felt a a a a friendship at
least from my side like a a bond
and when we left it suddenly hit me what
did I do that for what did I open myself
up to that because I and it was yeah it
was a real uh worry in that present
sense I think most people feel and I I'd
like to focus on this now that because
of his courage because of the way he'd
call less that kind of courage in the
nation and the amazing defense that they
put up for the for their freedom and
continue
to including now some offense to rightly
so to get their
freedom
um there was enough reasonable thought
that he would now be a martyr that you
wouldn't want to Target on that level so
I've let myself get a little
relaxed just you know superficially in
that sense but yeah there was there were
a couple of months that first two months
uh uh it was a bother has he seen the
movie yeah what do you think of it well
first of all he saw an earlier cut but
what was um you know we showed this
movie even
publicly as soon as we felt there were
times it would be a value to something
like we had shown it in Germany at one
time long before it was finished and I
would argue not in a good way but
because it more importantly than it
being a good movie or you know me being
proud of it filmic there were times
where we felt we had something that
would help the discussion go further and
that was our first
aim so because I only really finished
the movie a couple of months ago and
then so and he uh as in the movie as it
stands today you know you saw it the
first half hour is not easy on him not
very
complimentary and as a filmmaker he had
the patience to watch the whole thing
and so we walked into the office this is
sometime after I don't know we made
several trips I'd seen him several times
before this and this was the trip we
were making to show him the a rough cut
for the first time and so he he he saw
it sometime between 600 and 7:00 in the
morning before starting his day and we
saw him at about 4: in the afternoon
when we came into the office he's
standing there looking at me and he
said I bet you're glad I watched the
whole
thing I bet you were too yeah I was I
was because he does go on a journey I
mean and you're quite right you know to
tell the story of of the preface to this
war because it wasn't all as it is now
for zalinsky he wasn't this great he
wasn't a national hero never mind
International um there's another moment
in the movie um which rather selfishly I
like which is where I pop up uh but it's
quite interesting because it's a clip
from when I was doing my show at CNN and
I ask you a question but you don't
actually show the answer in the film
let's have a look what really motivates
you Shawn
pen the best response I've ever been
able to muster is that I'm curious I've
been lucky in life to be able to afford
to travel and weathered though it is my
famous face gets me access to places and
people I may otherwise not have known
and sometimes
I feel I can be
helpful so I had to wait 10 years for
the answer but there it
was uh it's an interesting one because
you know as always with everything you
do it's divided opinion uh you and you
said about this reaction you always get
I dream of a world where chickens can
cross the road without having their
motives question which I loved um but
you also said after you won the second
Oscar for milk you said I want to be
very clear that I do I do know how hard
I make it to appreciate me um and it
seems from this interview Sean that
you've certainly and maybe its age
wisdom experience I don't know stuff
going on in your life um it seems that
you've you've grown more self-aware
perhaps is that a fair
observation I think that there is some
um vanity
fatigue get to the point where I vanity
I don't have room for in my pack because
you've been accused obviously there's
too much of you in the movie and so on
but you make a joke of that several
times you know about you're not trying
to be Walter krony and they liken you to
haral and so on you're you're seeing
that joke but at the same time you're
also aware you wouldn't have got the
movie off first base if you weren't
front and center with this it wouldn't
have happened yeah and you know again it
had to do with recognizing and this was
a process first there was we couldn't
get the financing if I didn't wasn't on
camera very hard these these movies now
there's a great movie called freedom on
fire which is a a companion piece to
Winter on fire by gu ausi who was
nominated for Academy Award for winter
on fire about the maidan Revolution and
and he he he hasn't been able to get a
distributor for this thing because these
kinds of films are very difficult right
now I think he just showed it at the
Vatican to the pope and hopefully some
traction will come off of that but so
for us to get this thing done required
me being in it then you know to I I felt
like there again it was saying what's
the value added and of course I can be
mocked in whatever way but I do think we
were really successful
despite in the truth of how people can
benefit from this thing by offering
myself to it in a way that is kind of
like it's kind of one of the so like I
say here I I get I've get I've gotten
access to people and things that I know
wouldn't have come without my day job
supporting that and financially as well
as in terms of access to people and
that normally though it might not seem
it to people because I it gets covered I
have tried to avoid covering those trips
and what I'm actually doing and I
thought this time I'm going to let
people come with me and in the editing
it was really important to me I was you
know I make it clear I have opinions big
surprise but I also have played that
film and editing to myself without any
of my opinions
expressed to see if it still operates
and that's what was important to me so
anyone who's predisposed to doubting me
or not liking me or whatever it is just
doesn't like my Sour Puss face or
something they can ignore all of that
and still get what I'm what what the key
of this film is and I do think that we
that it has the it can be a a mechanism
by which people can come together a
little more and refocus what we had all
promised the ukrainians in the first
place when we all started putting our
Ukrainian Flags out and promised young
people that we would follow through and
if this is one more time we tell young
people we won't follow through as a
government as their parents as their
schools on this fundamental thing and
we're still aware that these These
People Like Us by that I mean Freedom
loving people who were attacked and uh
raped and kidnapped and murdered
and uh and separated from their families
you know that's a good way to create a
generation of Americans not much less
you know those in the battle Battlefield
who just are disenfranchised
disenfranchised mentally you've been
dipping your toe back into acting again
and you did say five years ago I'm not
in love with that anymore about acting
you falling a bit back in love with it
again well I had an experience that uh
surprised me yeah I did a movie called
dadia with Dakota Johnson directed and
written by a woman named Christy Hall
and it was kind of a gift of a piece
just really wonderfully written thing
and
U I hate admitting this part of it but
it was all run by
women better than other jobs I'd been on
really and uh and you sound surprised
sure no just you know embittered of my
original intent to be a you know
misogynist my own life um well you've
been quite interesting about that
because you said about that I'm in the
club that believes that men in American
culture have become wildly feminized I
don't think that being a brute or having
insensitivity or disrespect for women is
anything to do with masculinity or ever
did but I don't think that in order to
be fair to women we should become them
that's true too yeah yeah no I
look sometimes they say the toughest guy
on the Block is the one with the least
to
lose women have less to lose these days
and so they by toughest I think also
it's going to um see a generation where
there's um per capita more competence
what do you think of the current world
we live in where people no longer want
to say what a woman is for fear of being
cancelled I can't I'm bored with I think
I think let's talk about that when
people aren't being vaporized on the
front lines and of wars and you know I
I'm might I'm
I'm I'll stay out of judgment on it but
I'm not engaged in the conversation it
just
seems um not like the
priority there's a couple of other
Hollywood things that have happened
since I knew I was going to talk to you
one the Hollywood strikes got resolved
but that whole issue of AI you said
something very powerful about this you
said okay he said it's a moral for youh
uh AI being able to use your likeness
your voice to do stuff without you said
okay so you likened it to this you want
my scans and voice data and all that
okay here's what I think is fair I want
your daughters I want to create a
virtual replica of her and invite my
friends over to do whatever we want in a
virtual party right now would you please
look at the camera and tell me you think
that's cool yeah that was powerful and
when you're taking on head on the what
many perceive to be the IM ity of what
may be happening with AI and and
Hollywood yeah I think the um
thep uh were representative of an an
immoral and an in Indecent
Proposal and
that you know if if you or I or want to
sell or use or share that that data
power to anybody who wants to
selectively do that but even to ask to
own
anothers is uh you know we complain
about uh sexual harassment in the
workplace or well it's a robot
harassment yeah what you know and let me
see your medical records and let me see
you know it it's just it's do you think
there's a robot alive though Sean that
could possibly come close to replicating
Shawn
pen in all in all Your Glory yes because
it's not only functional robots that
we're seeing
made the other thing I wanted to ask you
about was the very sad death of Matthew
Perry because you appeared in several
episodes of friends and he suffered from
a lot of addiction issues he wrote an
incredible book about it one of the most
powerful books I've read what your son
Hooper had addiction issues and you
talked about that he said you saved his
his life your thoughts about
Matthew what a talented guy I can't
claim to have known him well but I liked
him very much I saw him somewhat
recently and we were both catching a
flight out Los Angeles airport and I you
know complimented him on um what I knew
of his book I hadn't read the book I had
seen SE several of his interviews and he
seemed to be talking about had
confronted it and and and was very
intelligent and and you know bold about
it and and and generously offering his
experience to people to be helpful um is
tra it's tragic I can't say I was
terribly surprised I I don't know what
the whole Corners report things and
everything but I know he had done a lot
of damage to his organs over the years
um you know tough tough situation
and you know he got to do that he got to
leave that tail behind and he he got to
give a lot of joy to a lot of people
with his talent and so you know uh I
wish his family well I want to end with
another quote from William
San this is also from the the stuff you
used to keep in your wall you still keep
it in your wallet or do you not I I do
but I run out of them very quickly
because I them to like a challenge coin
you said in the time of your life live
so that in the good time there should be
no ugliness or death for yourself or for
any life your life touches seek goodness
everywhere and when it's found bring it
out of its hiding place let it be free
and unashamed discover in all things
that which shines and is beyond
corruption and marage virtue and
whatever hard it may have been driven
into secrecy and Sorrow by the shame and
Terror of the world in the time of your
life live so that in that wondrous time
you shall not add to the misery and
sorrow of the world but shall smile to
the infinite delight and mystery of
it yeah I think that's it you know is
that your mantra for Life uh
increasingly yeah it's uh you know one
of the things we owe people who are
suffering is is uh to count our
blessings and and and enjoy while
counting them in our thoughts and our
actions but to really enjoy CU this is a
Magic World I've tried to maintain the
highest standards of Journalism for this
interview because you said recently I
still don't like journalism that focuses
on what toilet paper celebrities use out
of Interest what what toilet paper do
you use I've got a rule of Putin face
paper have you read it yeah somebody
gave it to me yeah you see
sometimes it slows questions to get the
best answers um and the other thing I
couldn't help but noticed because you
turned up with her here is you have a
new lady in your life Olga and she's
Ukrainian how did you how did you guys
mean um my good
luck she's here she is shall I shall I
get her into to ask
no but you're happy yeah very happy Sean
it's good to see you again great to see
you let's not leave us Al next time all
right and I love the movie I genuinely
think it's a an important timely and
Powerful film and I hope a lot of people
go and watch it because it tells you the
real story of Ukraine but also
accurately represents zalinski who has
been demonized by a lot of people now uh
for political expediency but actually I
think is the nearest thing to Churchill
we've seen since Churchill and was as
unpopular as Churchill before Churchill
did what he did right um but good luck
with it it's it's an important film
thanks a lot good to see you